speaking of which what should all
actress know about coming to Los Angeles
in terms of their career what suppose
someone's ready to buy that plane ticket
from wherever what are some of the
laundry listings that they need to know
about their career once they get well I
think that they should probably find a
community of actors meet actors have
conversations I have lots of
conversations all the time with people
try and figure out how to do it better
so to really engage people to connect to
read to find a good acting class a good
workshop a good seminar where they can
say I'm going to the gym I'm going to
the acting gym to figure out where would
be a good place to if they don't have
great pictures or great showreel to make
that happen and where they can start to
go and knock on doors and be seen be
seen let people know that they're here
that they've arrived
you